i do got to ask you though because like
online there's just been a lot of a lot
of stuff about steve
actually um crazy crazy conspiracy
theories
some people some people they think that
he's
in a secret base on the moon looking
down
over us it's finally here friends
marvel's the falcon and the winter
soldier
reintroduces two heroes who literally
helped save the universe
but are dealing with issues that can't
necessarily be solved by punching them
in the face that's not to say there's no
face punching because there is that
and kicking and my fave explosions
you know the drill major spoilers ahead
i'm carlos bustamante and this
is et canada's nerd
the show opens with a big action
sequence in the mighty marvel tradition
showcasing the falcon skills as he takes
on bat truck the leaper and his crew in
a high-speed
mid-air battle the scene seems like a
promise from the show's creators that
this series is going to deliver the
goods action-wise
what we see here i have no reason to
doubt them despite flying high as the
falcons sam wilson is facing some tough
times on the ground
the world is reeling from both the blip
and the loss of captain america steve
rogers
as the bearer of his shield sam
questions what that role means and if
anyone at all
including himself should bear that
symbol in modern america
in this thing
i don't know if there's ever been a
greater symbol
but it's more about the man who propped
it up
and he's gone so today we honor steve's
legacy but also
we look to the future
thank you captain america when sam goes
back home we're introduced to his sister
sarah and get a snapshot of their family
dynamic
one in which sam lives a surreal life
fighting space aliens and getting
blipped away for five years
while sarah has had the very real
responsibilities of
not only taking care of her own family
by herself but also trying to hold on to
the legacy and memories of their late
father
i thought we were going to discuss if we
were selling it we did
and then you were all fighting dr space
cake or whatever while i was holding it
together for five long years
now that the world is going back to
normal this thing got to go real life
gives sam a punch he may not have been
expecting
as even his superhero status means
little in the face of an unfair
unjust system you have no income over
the last five years
how can you have income if you don't
exist sarah meanwhile james buchanan
bucky barnes is living with his own
demons
as the former winter soldier he spent
decades as a brainwashed assassin
killing whoever he was assigned to plus
anyone else that might compromise his
missions
though he has since been freed of that
life fighting alongside the avengers
his long-term battle is with the ghosts
of his past actions
with bucky trying to make amends for all
how was the date
it was good it's a post-endgame world
and the blip has caused more chaos than
anyone could have ever expected
it's in this environment that a new
threat emerges the flag smashers
dangerous for sure their methods and
intent are not quite clear
yet though one thing is certain they
pack a mean punch
where could this power be coming from is
it the big three or maybe another
version of the super soldier program
that created captain america in the
first place
what big three androids aliens and
wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not oh yeah
speaking of captain america though sam
strongly believes that steve rogers was
a singular hero that should not be
replaced
the american government has other ideas
enter john walker the brand new captain
america
bearing the shield that steven trusted
to one person only
and it sure wasn't him oh boy
[Music]
what does the introduction of the new
cap mean for sam and bucky
especially considering sam technically
still works for the government of the us
of a
you know this is exactly what sam didn't
want to happen now of course
comic fans know john walker's story arc
on page but i'm super interested in
seeing
how this plays out on screen especially
considering there is no steve rogers for
the new captain america to go up against
so what did you think of the first
episode of the falcon in the winter
soldier is it giving you the big
cinematic action movie feel
how do you think baron zemo is going to
fit into all this and will this become
the weekly obsession
that one division was let's talk about
it in the comments below if you like
this video go ahead and give us a big
vibranium thumbs up
and if you're looking for more falcon in
the winter soldier stuff check out this
interview with anthony mackie and
sebastian stan where they tell me some
very interesting stories about working
with george st pierre then come on back
next week
for another recap see what i did there
cap
sorry i'm gonna i'll stop now i'm carlos
i'll see you next time